hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Dead Rising series has always been
the ultimate zombie hard killing
extravaganza here on PlayStation many
players have abandoned the series after
Dead Rising 3 was announced as an Xbox
exclusive over time it was released on
ps4 but then Dead Rising 4 was given a
timed exclusive on xbox so you can see
why many PlayStation gamers deserted the
franchise completely well Dead Rising
for Frank's big package GT share that's
actually its title is now on its way to
ps4 and is filled with extras and
additional content so if you want to
jump back into the series and make the
undead a little more dead then his six
reasons why Dead Rising 4 on ps4 is the
ultimate version of the game I'm
starting with the biggest anoint many
gamers have in the Dead Rising series
time restrictions and the stressed
attached to doing things within a proper
time frame remember how annoying it was
getting back to your doctor every single
day in Dead Rising 2 to give her a shot
of zom brace sweetie you okay Katie
Katie
well almost all time-based restrictions
in Dead Rising forth while the main game
at least have been removed allowing the
game to be the fun-filled zombie
massacre it always wanted to be the DLC
still has timed elements but those are
designed for players wanting more of a
challenge so don't feel too compelled to
take part in the timed madness if it's
not your back in the main game simply
explore and find hidden Easter eggs and
do what you do best
murder zombies the ps4 release of Dead
Rising or contains all the DLC released
over the last year that's the stocking
stuffer holiday pack Frank rising and
the super ultra Dead Rising for minigolf
the first is a Christmas themed pack
which added new weapon combinations
costume options and a host of little
other things
Frank rising on the other hand is a much
meteor edition with protagonist Frank
becoming one of the undead in an
extension to the core story this has a
possible three endings making the DLC
highly replayable
the minigolf DLC is a complete departure
from the core mechanics playing like
Tiger Woods golf with a focus on Mars on
be annihilated there's even more goodies
to with every single piece of bonus
content being included - from costumes
to ridiculous weaponry Street Fighter
outfits My Bloody Valentine pack a candy
cane crossbow a slice cycle and a ton
more editions you have to see to believe
so prepare yourself for levels of
customization which will take weeks to
truly uncover the ps4 version of the
game also includes a brand spanking new
game mode called Capcom heroes we all
know Capcom loved a good video game
crossover and this continues in Dead
Rising 4 with various Capcom characters
appearing so if you want to be a
six-foot version of Mega Man complete
with iconic weapons then Dead Rising 4
has you covered we could also be seeing
Resident Evil characters maybe Dante
from Devil May Cry and of course must be
5 to 2 references and you can shake a
zombie impaled stick
many offers in the playstation ecosystem
tuned out top dead rising fours initial
advertising run due to the xbox kind
exclusivity you may not know that there
is a four-player cooperative mode in
Dead Rising for these are an absolute
blast
and could be the greatest addition to
the game and add so many hours of extra
playtime to so when can we get our
collective hands on Frank's big package
now there's at the host it will be
released on December the 5th so a
potential stocking filler for a loved
one are a great way to avoid your family
during the winter holidays or summer
holidays if you're from a different
atmosphere so let's be frank about Frank
and Dead Rising even though this game is
a year old the additional content brings
it bang up-to-date for PlayStation users
will you be grabbing it please let me
know your thoughts oh and what do you
think about thymes exclusivity does it
make you abandon brands or switch
consoles I'm going to be making a video
on exclusivity and I would love to
include your comments I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade and a reminder we
now have a discard I'll put the details
below if you're interested it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time